this is what flows my mind to dig back
into the volcker rule doesn't it feel
like we are getting in the weeds if you
remember it took them a year and a half
to even agree on what the term
market-making meant now we want to get
deep into hft well I mean so just to
separate the two things i think the
volcker rule component of this based on
the reporting i've seen so far and like
david says this all hasn't been released
yet so this is a premature but this it
seems to be targeting this percentage
that are allowed to own in funds you
know it basically Goldman Sachs or JP
Morgan used to be able to own a hundred
percent of a hedge fund now they only
can own three percent it's hard to know
how much risk there really isn't three
percent of a fund but maybe it looks
good to say okay well get is it just for
show well I mean politics you know
that's not just for show in politics
daunting we're not saying things are
completely fixed since the financial
crisis but we're gonna go into this big
plan about three person thing I don't
understand is okay three percent on out
of a hedge fund says whether the hedge
fund goes belly-up why isn't the
relevant question how much of the bank's
reserves and capital is involved
invested well I mean that's also in the
Volcker rule as I remember it at they
can't have more than three percent of
their capital in a hedge fund either so
it kind of works both ways but what I
would say is that the more interesting
thing is really the part that hasn't
been mentioned which is how they how
they where they put the swaps within the
financial companies right now they're
allowed to have it in the deposit taking
part of the bank there's been a lot of
brouhaha led by the Elizabeth Warren a
side of the of the aisle and and
Hillary's proposal seems to be saying
they want to go back to that this
basically completely cramp any
derivatives type businesses based on
where they would need keep to keep all
these reserves right what's your take
Steve not really my world I don't focus
so much on derivatives and hedge funds I
focus more on the startups and the
entrepreneurs and the and the venture
capital side of things like more focus
on that and how we use it really use
that as a lever to create jobs and drive
economic growth i think is where I
really focus so can I just let's just I
mean so you must be investing in some
financial technology companies that are
looking to disrupt the way that these
Wall Street bank I mean that's another
threat more and more so than maybe the
politicians is what companies like yours
can do in terms of creating new
competitor yeah I think its threat
obviously it for entrepreneurs it's an
opportunity financial services like
other sectors health and education
really ripe for disruption and you'll
see in some of these kind of
conglomerates kind of breakdown as its
disruptive entrepreneur they're
attacking different slices of that what
had been a kind of a integrated strategy
and that's going to take hold of the
next decade or so I praised great
opportunities but puts pressure on the
incumbent so I think it's great about
entrepreneurs they're kind of the
attackers kind of challenging the status
quo the large companies or the
incumbents trying to protect the the
status quo and that we've seen that play
out media and communications a lot of
sectors in the next decade health
education energy transportation
financial services food they are all up
for grabs as entrepreneurs are really
starting to focus much more time doing
any of that I know John Mack has come in
later is involved in we have done some
where we invest across the economy
really trying to invest in people and
ideas that can change the role really
improve how people do their kind of
everyday lives and disrupt big sectors
of the economy financial services and
fintech what they call it certainly one
area we're focused on to come back to
Stephanie's question which I really
strikes me this is politics it is a
political season it's an election I
understand all that what is the audience
that Hillary Clinton is trying to
address with these four I mean the
average person the person you start
talking about high frequency trading and
what percentage of a hedgehog is it out
there saying I'm gonna vote for that
person for presidents was that because
it's three percent or two percent or
four percent of them I just political
expert but I think she's got a debate
coming up next week and she's gonna be
debating people who made taking on Wall
Street a big plank of their of their own
haven't we taken them on already well
but i think but i think that's almost a
point of all the things a candidate
could go after right now I feel like
Wall Street we got them yeah when you
present it does resonator I agree a lot
of people are still frustrated out there
a lot of people feel left behind a
little have been a lot of growth and a
lot of companies a lot of growth and
wealth this opportunity gap is as wide
and some people call it income
inequality that is frustrating and it
clearly is resonating and that is
tapping it the whole Bernie Sanders
movement a lot of that is people saying
they're kind of fed up with washing
they're fed up with the status quo they
want to kind of take take on you know
the you know the the wall street and so
that some of the big banks so it does
resonate and get that in a general sense
we want to take on Wall Street but that
translates into and she is talking
apparently about holding individual
executives personally responsible people
get that Ben Bernanke's can talk about
that that good I just don't get this
technical stuff well I understand what I
would say is that people I sort of
innately understand that there's
something in their lives that's helped
by some of the companies at Steve backs
are these startups like the new
technology Apple Google and they get why
that helps their lives they don't really
understand well this fast trading does
it's hard for Wall Street to make a case
why you need this sort of micro second
trading and why it makes your life
better and then sometimes they read that
it causes things like the flash crash
and I think the ants don't make
something that's in your home that makes
your life better so politically it's
harder to defend then you know starting
a new technology don't make anything so
I really making product service is more
about moving money around and it's
important part of the economy but I
think I think most people in the country
really want to figure out what are the
what are the people that are creating
the products services can't improve
their lives they can relate to are
creating a companies that are creating
jobs and opportunities in their
communities not just in a in a few
places so that that's the real world